122 seats 7 million NPCs vote for PSOE
after releasing rapists andos
making pacts with terrorists
indult independentistas
after buying votes
and assault the constitutional court
bad thinking of public funds
achieve 1 CPI increase
which turns into 1 luxury item
be able to GO to Mercadona
after lowering their pants against Morocco
after raising taxes and creating new taxes
after encouraging illegal occupation of housing
eliminate the crime of sedition
and reform the adversation issue
so that when they steal
your thefts go unpunished
after emptying the budget items
days before the elections
for his fear of leaving his precious chair
I would like to withdraw the money with phantom expenses
after increasing the public debt
in 400 million euros
that means that you Spanish
you now owe €78,000 to the state
for the fact of being Spanish
and for relying on the management of the left-wing government
7 million Spaniards
dominated by profound inculturation
populism,
fear andness
7 million Spaniards who do not want to be free
who are not free and who are afraid to be free
She said so
Autobomis Mark Spain is the strongest country in the world
Silos has been trying to destroy himself
and has not yet made it
maybe now on the left I will finish making it.